DALE MARKOWITZ: Some
people are born athletes,
other people are born Mathletes.
And me?
Well, I've been failing
gym since the second grade.
So I always thought
it would make sense
to take something simpler,
like software engineering.
And this basically describes
my lifelong relationship
with sports until
a couple of months
ago when I learned that my
friend, Zack Akil, who's
both a software
engineer, but also
a competitive rugby player,
was working on a project
to analyze soccer kicks
using machine learning.
So in this episode of "Making
With Machine Learning,"
we'll talk to Zack
to see how he did it.
And then I'll try to adapt his
techniques to my tennis serve.
Stick around to see how
I did it and how you
can do it with your own data.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So I wanted to talk
to you because I
heard that you built a
really cool demo at London
Next this year, using
machine learning
to analyze how people
were able to kick a soccer
ball for a penalty shot?
Did I get that right?
ZACK AKIL: Yeah.
Everything except
for the soccer bit.
It was actually a football demo.
DALE MARKOWITZ: Football?
It didn't look that way
to me from the video.
ZACK AKIL: No, it was football.
We call it football over here.
DALE MARKOWITZ: Yeah.
So Zack, why did you
decide to build this demo?
ZACK AKIL: Well, we have a
partnership with the Football
Association, and we were just
sort of spitballing ideas
as to what would be a really
cool way of highlighting both
the sport and some
really cool things you
can do with machine learning.
DALE MARKOWITZ: So what exactly
were you doing with that demo?
I wish I could have been there.
ZACK AKIL: Yeah.
So we were using three
different cameras
to track people's accuracy,
power, and the very style
of their kick.
They go on to the pitch,
they line up the ball.
We give them the
instructions-- three kicks,
and they all get recorded.
I was there with a whistle.
The people who
were organizing it
didn't know I was going
to bring a whistle,
but I brought it anyway.
I'd blow the whistle.
They would kick the ball.
They would try to hit one of
two targets in the top left
and top right corners.
After three kicks, they
would see on a live dashboard
the results of the power,
the accuracy, and the style
of each one of their kicks.
After that, they would get
their own player profile card.
DALE MARKOWITZ: So
tell me about how
you took all of this
machine learning technology,
and you put it into
an actual phone app.
ZACK AKIL: Ooh.
So that's a good
question because we
did have three mobile
phones recording
from different angles.
We have one camera placed
down on the ground.
Its only job is to track
the ball on its way
to the goal from the side.
And by tracking the
ball from this angle,
we can easily see the
speed of the ball.
And then the next camera we have
is positioned above head height
and behind the kicker,
looking directly at the goal.
And this camera tracks where
the targets are on the goal.
And then the last
camera, that's positioned
kind of at a 45 degree
angle, facing the kicker.
And this is purely for
the Video Intelligence API
to run its pose estimation on.
The API will pick
out the coolest shot,
and then that frame is used
on the player profile card.
For tracking the
ball's speed, we
did some high
school mathematics,
where it was the difference
in space over time
to work out the
speed of the ball.
And then to work out
accuracy, because we also
had binding boxes
for the targets
within the goal
returned, we just
did like a Euclidean distance
to the nearest target.
So that was accuracy
and speed pretty easy.
And then the last one was style.
I mean, how can you
measure style, really?
So we had to just come up
with our own metric of what
was the most stylish kick.
DALE MARKOWITZ: So
what went into it?
What was the technology
stack that powered your demo?
ZACK AKIL: For the kind of
really cool stuff, the machine
learning, we used
AutoML to build
the tracking models of the ball
and the targets and the goal.
And to analyze the
posture of the player,
we were actually
using a feature that's
soon to be released,
called Pose Estimation.
DALE MARKOWITZ: The feature
that Zack's talking about here
is actually called
Person Detection.
And it's now available through
the Video Intelligence API.
ZACK AKIL: When
you give it a video
and there's people
in the video, it
will estimate the
skeleton, and where it is,
and where each joint is.
DALE MARKOWITZ: What are all of
the different machine learning
problems that you faced
as you were building this?
ZACK AKIL: The first challenge
that we knew we wanted to solve
was just tracking the ball.
We figured, OK, a football
is a pretty generic object.
Maybe there's a pre-trained
model that we can utilize.
And what we found was when
you take a picture or a frame
from a video of a kick,
the ball is too blurry
to then be picked up by a
generic pre-trained model.
And that was the first
challenge, was OK,
we had to train our
own vision model
to detect a blurry football.
So I built two auto ML models.
Here's the first one, which is
the tracking of the accuracy.
And you can see here,
if I click on image,
you can see where we've
labeled the images.
Using the tool, we draw
boxes around things.
So if I want to draw
a box around that,
we drew a box around it and told
it what we wanted it to track.
DALE MARKOWITZ: So
you have two targets
that are on the goalpost and the
ball annotated in this model?
ZACK AKIL: Yep.
Exactly, yeah.
After we've labeled some
data, to train a model
it was really easy.
You just go to the Train
tab, and there's a button.
And you can see here we actually
trained a couple of models.
By clicking Train Your
Model, it will give us
some questions about
it, like, how long do
we want to train the model for?
But it was effectively
just that one click,
and we would get a new model.
So here's an example of
the predictions it makes
and how it ranks itself.
So we've got this camera
looking from the side view
to track the ball going across.
And you can see
in this instance,
the ball's a bit blurry.
And that's why we needed
to train a custom model,
because a generic
pre-trained model didn't
recognize this as a football.
DALE MARKOWITZ: So do you
play soccer, slash, football?
ZACK AKIL: No, I hate football.
I'm more into rugby.
DALE MARKOWITZ: Now that I
understood Zack's technique,
I went to the
tennis court to see
if I could use it to
improve my tennis serve.
I used the Video
Intelligence API
to track my skeleton,
which let me calculate
the angles of my arms and legs.
And I trained an
AutoML Vision model
to track the trajectory
of the tennis
ball and calculated speed
as it zoomed into the net.
The math revealed what
I'd always sort of known
about my tennis serve--
it stinks.
But check out my blog
linked in the description
to see how I'm using
these stats to get better.
That's all for now.
See you next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]